this is the other animated Disney flick
that I'm sort of gonna cheat on tangled
I know technically it's a 3d animated
movie but let's be honest it's a 2d film
in 3ds clothing characters are designed
like 2d animation the backgrounds look
like something out of 2d animation the
story is very reminiscent of the
traditional Disney fairy tales it's
basically a 2d animated flick so I'll
bend the rules a little bit and review
this one as well and I also feel it a
little bit necessary to compare it to
the last 2d anime film The Princess and
the Frog I know that's probably not fair
to the movie but at the same time one
film only did okay and one film did a
lot better and this was the one that did
a lot better and seeing how they came
out back-to-back I guess it does make
sense to see why one did better than the
other so let's talk about the absolute
best aspect of the film the story and
it's rare that I say that but the story
to this film is brilliant this is the
classic retelling of a fairy tale that
Disney used to do best
it's not exactly like the original but
the changes are not only incredibly
creative but half the time they're
improvements it transitions the story
into film perfectly okay so what is it
apparently there's this magic flower
that gives eternal youth but it only
seems to do it when you sing a certain
song that this witch figured out so the
witch has been using the flower for
years that is until the queen of the
land gets incredibly sick so the flower
is found and used to keep her alive but
the witch loses her ability to keep
young seems the flower has been crushed
down to herbs and has now been passed on
to the Queen's daughter Rapunzel and the
quote-unquote flower power actually
seems to be in her hair so the witch
kidnaps Rapunzel when she's just a baby
and uses the power of her hair to grow
younger and seeing how she wants to live
longer and longer she grows the hair
longer and longer all throughout this
introduction I was shouting brilliant
brilliant brilliant this is a fantastic
setup there's a reason for the hair to
grow long there's a reason for her to be
in a tower there's a reason to
incorporate music into this it was just
wonderful
and on top of that the setup for the
rest of the story is actually pretty
good too
Rapunzel grows up into a teenager of
course under the care of her controlling
witch mother but when a famous
enters her tower she knocks him mouth
and tries to get some information out of
him he agrees that if she lets him go
he'll lead her to this ceremony that
seems to take place every year on her
birthday this ceremony it turns out is
raising a bunch of lanterns in the hope
that someday she will find it and return
back home she agrees and from here on in
it's pretty much the adventure you think
it'd be their sword fighting horse
riding dancing singing romances
evildoers all the stuff you'd expect
from Disney so just from that ingenious
set up you'd expect this to be maybe one
of the top 5 Disney films of all time
right well there are some problems one
is the voice acting don't get me wrong
it's not terrible it's not even that bad
I just can't find myself getting that
invested in these voices as soon as I
heard Rapunzel's voice remember thing to
myself oh that's a celebrity voice and
would you know it it was and as soon as
I heard the thief's voice I remember
thinking hey that sounds like a guy
trying to do a thief's voice but not
actually a fee and that's my major
problem with this movie as brilliant as
the set up is everything feels like
they're trying to convey that
traditional Disney film sometimes it
works but other times
much like hunchback it feels pretty
forced like the musical segments they
just sort of come out of nowhere they
feel very rushed and I don't feel like
it really matches the movie I mean
granted I'm not a big fan of Randy
Newman but it matched in The Princess
and the Frog
it was noir leans it made sense to have
that kind of music here this sort of pop
guitar slash broadway slash billboards
hits sound i don't know it seems a
little out of place and honestly those
two things are my only problem but
they're kind of a big problem princess
and the frog it was the story and
everything else is fine this the story
is great but everything else seems kind
of done now don't get me wrong
there are some real standout moments in
fact i'll tell you my two favorites one
is the horse this is one of the great
movie horses he's like the Chabert of
horses it's just a grey character I
could watch this thing forever he just
cracks me up the other is the animation
on the parent now that's really
interesting because they never have a
line in this movie but holy smokes
look at the reaction on their faces look
out torn apart they are better
some of the best emotion I've ever seen
in any animation and it's all done
without words but still that doesn't
make up for the two main characters and
as I said before they're not bad they're
well-written and they look great I
honestly just think it's the voice work
and even then it's not horrible I'm just
always aware I'm hearing somebody behind
a microphone I'm always hearing somebody
acting I'm always hearing somebody put
out a performance and when you're
constantly hearing that you can't get as
invested so why did this film do a lot
better as opposed to the last film about
a princess and The Princess and the Frog
is it a race issue it could be is it
because there's more guitar playing pop
songs that can appeal to the general
public more than ragtime New Orlean
sound that's possible too but again I
think it comes back to my original
theory 3d animation I think the film did
well because the advertising played up
that there's gonna be more adult jokes
even though there weren't that many the
fact that the story to its credit was a
lot more simpler than princess in the
frog and like I said the fact that this
3d animation makes adults think that
it's gonna be made for them too so do I
like it sure it's a good flick well the
voice acting is distracting it doesn't
destroy the film I mean I'm with it
enough the background still look nice
there's a few genuine soft moments the
side characters are fun and like I said
it's a great story I guess for me I just
like the updates to the Disney formula
in The Princess and the Frog more than I
like the updates in Tangled
somewhere there's a brilliant Disney
movie here if we took the story of
tangled and the animation and characters
of Princess and the Frog we could get
something as brilliant as Beauty and the
Beast it's in there I know it but still
if you're looking for a good adventure
that also has that fairytale edge to it
tangles not a bad rent check it out and
see what you can get wrapped up
that I see